Speaker 1: Not going to spend a ton of time
on this, but Mike Lindell is really starting
to get frustrated that Donald Trump still
hasn't been reinstated. Here he is on this
same program where it's his show, the Lindell
Report. But he often calls in as a guest in
this case from a car. And he says he's got the
royal flush and somehow Trump still hasn't been
reinstated. And he's very frustrated by this.
Speaker 3: When you have when I'm sitting
on this kind of evidence, we are and then I am,
and you can't it's like having a royal flush in
a poker game, but you can't play. You're here.
I'm tired of it. You know, you have a royal
flush. I want the game to end and get back to,
you know, get our country back here.
Let's get this. Get this evidence out
in the open for the whole world to see. And.
Speaker 1: Yeah, he hasn't actually shown anyone
the evidence in his post. Remember last week,
Mike Pillow was posting all over our Facebook
page. He said that the evidence is as follows
They captured packets from China. They presented
everything at the symposium and China was caught
red handed. Not exactly an overwhelming case.
Here's another one of these examples from
a few days ago. Lindell said his cyber guys
went through the data and they found it. They
found everything. And if you listen closely,
you'll probably come away saying they found what?
Speaker 3: I have really great news. Good. Well,
call it great news is 4%. There's only 4% of those
counties so far that I cyber guys have looked at
that are not compromised. In other words, 96%
of all the counties we've went through already,
which is hundreds of them, have all been machine
manipulated. Yep. And and this is 100% evidence.
Speaker 1: So that's it's evidence,
as he calls it. Also another major
declaration from Mike Pillow.
Speaker 3: Hello, I'm Mike Lindell
and Junior. Incredible support the original.
My slippers are almost completely sold out.
Speaker 1: Okay. So anyway, I consider the
slipper news basically as important as his
claims they're about about the evidence. This
guy is furious that Trump hasn't been reinstated
and it's all absolutely and completely
pathetic. And we're going to watch whether
anything actually ever happens. But it seems
what's happening now that his phone has been
seized by the FBI is the so-called evidence
is going to be evidence in a potential trial
against pillow than evidence that Trump should be
reinstated. Incredible how the tables have turned